in this video you're going to learn how
to solve three variables three equations
to find the equation of a quadratic or a
parabola given three points on the
parabola so what we're going to do is
we're going to take each of these points
individually and we're going to make an
equation using our quadratic equation
here so you can see that when Y is 10
X is equal to 3. so I'm just
substituting in our X and Y
and I'm going to make an equation using
each one of these points so for the
second point you can see Y is 6 when a
is negative one I'm sorry when X is
negative one
and Y equals three when X is equal to 2.
okay so now we have our three variables
three equations we're going to solve for
our a b and c by using the elimination
method so the first thing I want to do
is just simplify these equations a
little bit just to make them a little
bit easier to work with so we've got 3
squared is 9 times a is 9A
3 times B gives us 3B plus C is equal to
10. so I just change the left and right
sides of the equation just to make it
read a little bit easier negative 1
squared is 1 times a is a minus B plus C
is equal to 6 and then our third
equation we have 2 squared is 4 times a
plus two B
plus C is equal to three okay so these
are the three variable three equations
that we're going to work with to solve
for a b and c now you want to pick a
variable to eliminate either the A's the
B's or the C's and I'm going to
eliminate the C's in this case because
you can see there's just like one C it
looks like it's going to be pretty easy
to eliminate so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to subtract this top equation
I'm going to take the top equation minus
the middle equation so if I do that the
Seas will cancel out so we have 9A minus
1A which is equal to
8A 3B minus negative 1B is 4B because
remember when you subtract a negative
it's like adding the opposite and C
minus C is 0 and 10 minus 6 is equal to
4. now we've worked with the first and
second equations now we have to use that
third equation you can either try to
combine it with the first or with the
second I'll just use the second equation
and I'll do that same technique where
I'm going to take the second equation
minus the third equation so just
subtracting so 1A minus 4A gives us
negative 3A negative 1B minus 2B gives
us negative 3B
and C minus C gives us 0 and 6 minus 3
gives us 3.
okay so now look what we have we have
two variables two equations we can solve
this system we need to either eliminate
the A's or the B's I'm going to
eliminate the B's and what we need to do
is find the lowest common multiple for
four and three so what do four and three
both go into
12 so I'm going to multiply this top
equation by 3 so that'll give us 12b I'm
going to multiply this bottom equation
by 4 that will give us negative 12 B
then we can add the two equations
together to eliminate the B's so first
thing let's just distribute distribute
the 3 to the whole equation make sure
you do it to the left and right sides
let's multiply this bottom equation by 4
and now what we can do is we can add
straight down so 24a minus 12a is 12a
the 12b and negative 12b cancel and 12
plus 12 is 24. now if we divide both
sides of the equation by 12 you can see
we're getting a is equal to 2. okay so
now what we're going to do is work our
way backwards we're going to take a
equals 2 put it to one of the two
variable equations solve for b then go
back to one of our three variable
equations and solve for C so it's like
back substitution so if we put 2 in
let's put in this top equation we have 8
times 2
plus four b equals 4 so that's 16 plus
4B equals four subtract 16 from both
sides that's negative 12 and divide by 4
you can see we're getting B is equal to
negative 3. now we just need to solve
for C let's see I think I'm going to use
this bottom equation here so we have 4
times a which is 2 plus 2 times B which
is negative 3 plus C equals three now I
could have put it into the first or
second equation I just picked this third
one just because I have some space here
to write so it'd be a little bit easier
for us to see so 8 minus 6 plus C equals
three that gives us 2 plus C is equal to
three and if we subtract 2 from both
sides you can see that we're getting C
is equal to one so if we put everything
back into our equation there let's see
what we have we've got Y is equal to a
which is two so that's 2x squared
we have B which is negative three so
negative three x and we have C is equal
to one
and that's the equation of our Parabola
our like some more practice and you want
to try one of these on your own try this
one where you have the points 2 21 1 4
and negative 213. go ahead and make your
system of three variables three
equations see if you can solve it and I
want to show you the answer here in just
a second but I just want to mention if
you're enjoying my content and you want
to support the channel consider joining
as a channel member so check out that
link I'll put it in the description and
if you want to see some more examples of
how to solve three variable equations
and specifically how to find the
equation of the parabola I'll put a
video up there that you can check out go
over to that video and I'll see you in
that video but the final answer for this
one is 5X squared plus 2X minus 3 y
equals so great job I'll see in the next
video